plus est sur le plan sanitaire
l'épidémie de coronavirus est désormais
contrôlée c'est le président du conseil
scientifique le professeur jean françois
delfraissy que la firme le groupe
d'experts envisage quatre scénarios pour
les mois à venir mais exclut dans tous
les cas un nouveau confinement
généraliser la conséquence certains
c'est pas assoupli en mesure de
restriction dans le but d'accueillir des
visiteurs illustration dans un
établissement du val-de-marne
reportage signé mona mode lionel girard
est dédié ce cas après quasiment trois
mois d'isolement
ces retraités peuvent à présent recevoir
les visites de leur famille avec moins
de restriction dans cet ehpad du val de
marne
les retrouvailles ont pu avoir lieu
entre cette dame et son fils au cours
des semaines précédentes
la résidante a dû faire avec les
difficultés du confinement oliart on a
chip et on fait tout ce qu on demande de
faire
bonjour au bâillon
on joue avec des baguettes
enfin on passe en temps comme un peu
comme un pansement jamais tu as pu
remarquer que steam même beaucoup ici
fait que de l'autre côté il l'a vu une
camionnette ils ont mangé les boules à
la mèche depuis ce vendredi
les résidents peuvent recevoir plus de 2
proche à la fois et sans séparation par
une vitre les assouplissement des règles
de visites dans les ehpad d'exclus pas
certaines mesures à respecter cette
infirmière cadre de santé insiste sur
l'importance des gestes barrières
donc effectivement les gestes barrière
dans ce genre de situation sont
primordiales c'est ce qui permet
effectivement de limiter la
contamination au sein de l'établissement
donc malgré l'assouplissement on a
maintenu une multitude de choses on a
fait une petite note à l'entrée tous les
agents en arrivant donc se lave les
mains avec la solution hydro alcoolique
il désinfecte leurs clés et leur
portable avec le produit virucide
ensuite ils mettent tous les jours une
blouse propre un masque et ensuite ils
sont prêts pour pouvoir intégrer les
étages et allait s'occuper des résidents
avec des mesures plus souples et une
fréquentation plus importante le
personnel doit s'organiser et veiller à
rassurer les personnes âgées souvent
très vulnérable elle reste concerné en
première ligne par le coronavirus de son
côté la directrice de l'établissement
estime que les annonces du gouvernement
n'intervienne pas au moment opportun
pour elle ces mesures d'assouplissement
ont besoin d'être organisés ils ont
annoncé ça donc le week-end de la
pentecôte donc c'est ils annoncent ce
jour ils font toujours des annonces le
week-end c'est bien parce que nous du
coup les directeurs ce n'est pas de moi
qu'on gère la crise on n'est pas fatigué
puis le week-end du coup il faut qu'on
soit branché parce que sinon revient au
bureau et on n'a pas compris quoi et
il ya un effet d'annonce c'est vrai qui
est vrai et en plus ça répond à un
besoin des familles donc toutes les
familles pense que là ce week-end c'est
la fête des mères tout le monde peut
venir offrir son bouquet est en fait non
nous on a reçu un communiqué de la part
de la de la dgs ou en fait c'est très
cetrel avc de la dgcs c'est très précis
en fait c'est très restrictif encore
donc ça correspond pas à l'annoncé qui a
été faite dans les médias pour pour la
fois la population globale
alors que certains ehpad ont décidé de
rouvrir leurs portes d'autres ont fait
le choix de rester fermés malgré
l'annoncé du gouvernement
ce week-end pour la fête des mères
plusieurs établissements mis en place
des systèmes d'envoi de courrier
toujours dans un même but celui de
préserver la santé des résidents